[MUSIC PLAYING]
I have always
felt, if you know
what you're going to do in
advance, then you won't do it.
Your creativity starts with
whether you're curious or not.
Roll 'em.
Go.
Action.
When you build a
building-- any building--
start with a simple block
model to see where that goes.
Most of our cities are built
with just faceless glass,
only for economies and
not for humanities.
As an artist, I got constraints.
Gravity is one of them.
But within all
those constraints,
I have 15% of freedom
to make my art.
I'm always trying
to express movement.
I was fascinated with the fold,
so basic to our first feelings
of love and warmth.
These ideas are scary as
hell to tell to the client.
They can reject
you, and they will.
But you've got to
find your own voice.
Create the logic
for it as you go.
Stretch it into another place.
I'm just telling you how
I did it and why I did it.
Whatever you do, promise me
that every project you make
or design, you'll take the
risk of doing something
for humanity.
I'm Frank Gehry, and
this is my Masterclass.
You would think I'd
know when to quit.